So now that we know that we have four
mobile constraints, that we can't violate when we're building
and designing mobile applications our users are going to have
a really bad time. Let's deep dive into these four.
>> Yeah, we'll talk about what happens when you actually do get
them wrong, and what the implications are to your user in your app.
>> So let's get started with a quiz.
>> So we have an application here on the screen. And as you can
see a user is using this media player application to actually play a video.
So you can see a couple of things, it's on a three g network. The power is about
half, it's 3:20 pm I guess, the application is in
landscape mode. And they've played about halfway through the video. We can also
see that the app has defaulted to 1080p resolution to
play this video. So there is a ux fail happening
here. I want you to think about which one of
these elements that I've highlighted are contributing to this fail, and
select it on the screen.